what up space fam golden here from anime
up we're back at it again to discuss the
latest and craziest developments in the
one piece story and wow i said last time
i've never been more excited to see the
next chapter and it did not disappoint
we see the aftermath of the kaido vs
luffy fight it officially concludes
according to the narrator we see luffy
awaken his fruit and we find out
joyboy's true identity so make sure to
stay tuned for this amazing chapter if
you do enjoy seeing these reviews and
want to keep them coming you know what
to do chill the pirate king within and
smash that like button with no mercy
remember smashing his pirate king energy
and passing his scared orochi energy so
choose wisely if you haven't make this
the video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates and while
you wait for the next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my huge one-piece
playlist that includes videos on all
admirals yonko supernova and more link
to that is in the description and now
without further ado let's jump into its
spoilers and all this chapter is called
we die together another hyped title that
really emphasizes how big the stakes are
right now we pick up right where we left
off with kaido delivering an
overwhelming blow to luffy kaido's face
shows his displeasure at the fact that
the cp-0 agent interfered luffy exhales
and goes flying around until he hits the
ground looking pretty dead as if to
confirm this we see momo sensing that
luffy's voice is gone now it might be
weird for us to hear that the
protagonist is dead because obviously
the protagonist isn't dead since he's
the protagonist but shonen do this
nonetheless and in this case it seems
more like a symbolic death to signify
that luffy has become something else but
more on that later back to kaido the
narrator straight up says that the
victor is kaido king of the beasts and i
just gotta say i respect that oda made
the narrator say that we were primed to
hear that the victor was luffy after our
guys were proclaimed winner again and
again all leading up to this final
battle but oda used that built up
expectation and delivered a solid twist
at this point raidwolf failed theorists
probably got very excited but the last
part of the chapter definitely makes it
less likely that the raid will fail as
we'll get into again i think wording is
important and we're told the victor
between strawhat luffy and kaido was
kaido but later we're going to get a
battle between kaido and a new being so
to speak and that battle will have its
own victor which will most likely be
luffy's latest version of himself kaido
then turns to cpz our agent as we
predicted and as he did with the old
lady that interfered with the odin fight
he goes to end the dude's whole career
he hits him point blank and it's made to
look like he's done since he already had
damage from drake too since we don't see
a body or anything we definitely can't
assume he's dead but i think we can at
least say kaido tried to end him as he
did with the shape-shifting old lady
last time his fight was interrupted i
also suggest the last chapter that kaido
may have changed over time and might
allow luffy to heal rather than
finishing him off as he did with odin
after the fight was interrupted and oda
found a way to do this sort of instead
of kaido letting it hurt luffy recover
because of a sense of honor he leaves
him alone to recover because he thinks
he's already dead still not needing to
show everyone else that he killed luffy
does seem like progress as the ceiling
caves in from kaido's attack we see the
other cp-0 agent and i'm guessing he's
giving a tilt of his hat to his fallen
comrade but it's hard to read these guys
with their expressionless masks we then
jump to kawamatsu who is dealing with
the fire again he reiterates that they
can't quell the fire so everyone needs
to find a way out there is no honor in
burning alive and oda has been
emphasizing this big time throughout the
arc don't be quick to accept an
avoidable death because you think it
will bring you honor keep trying to
survive if possible then kaido shows up
to everyone's surprise in his dragon
form he's asking where their leader momo
is he wants him to declare his surrender
and he states that straw hat luffy is
dead and i just want to personally add
and sun god luffy is born but of course
kaido doesn't say that kaido is truly a
beast though in every sense of the word
and seems completely fine after his
prolonged battle with luffy saying that
if any still wish to fight they should
step forward it's a really cool move and
the dude just exudes so much epic yonko
energy his own men started celebrating
that it's a total victory for kaido and
of course this builds up morale on their
side law also states that luffy's voice
has vanished further implying he's gone
the supernova reactions are interesting
kid says looks like we were kidding
ourselves and lost says it's a bitter
pill to swallow he says he's got nothing
left chopper starts crying and again i
want to be like you have little faith
chopper but at least nami and tama don't
believe it tama's reaction is pretty
heartbreaking because she's crying says
big bro and you know she already had to
go through this with aces loss so her
reaction probably affects me the most
here back to nami who says luffy can't
have lost he's not dead it's impossible
kaido sees that some still won't let
their spirits break and he answers with
a breath blast only to have it stopped
by marco the phoenix who tells them not
to give up until it's over for someone
who doesn't believe kaido though nami is
pretty torn apart laying there on the
ground trembling when nami gets like
this it can't help but affect us
especially when we juxtapose how
different it is to her usual i just want
to make money self i want to see zorro
or sanji just calmly being like no way
luffy's dead but we obviously don't get
that here and zoro is probably not
getting up anytime soon kaido then shows
why he's clearly not joyboy joyboy is
associated with liberation and kaido
says this country is a weapons factory
to him he doesn't care if they're woman
or children everyone is his slave so
yeah kaido is no hero no surprise there
there was a rebellion and now he's going
to make sure his enemies work until they
drop dead that's how they'll live the
rest of their miserable lives according
to him there's a great terrifying panel
of him saying you chose to oppose me
facing my wrath now should come as no
surprise and although he's morally wrong
to do it it's realistic and everyone
should have expected as much or worse if
kaido won a samurai is panicking saying
no please spare my wife and child but it
ain't happening as kaido says that is
what it means to lose in war you gambled
with your rights and dreams he then says
this doesn't end until they bring him
momo in the meantime weak extra beast
pirates go to finish off the weekend kid
in law since they are high off of
kaido's victory our two supernova look
like they can't even move and their men
step in to protect them one dude also
says kaido is tougher than a fortress
which is a cool line and i have to agree
with that kaido just might be the
physically toughest dude i can think of
panic is the general state of things as
people run around looking for a way out
as the flames spread kid in law get up
kid says i'm fighting surrendering or
letting him kill us are both out of the
question and you gotta love it i've been
saying for a long time i love kid's
character and this attitude in the face
of another yonko coming after he beat
the first is just so respectable and
commendable law doesn't sound quite as
determined and he's more upset with
luffy for not pulling off his side of
the deal but we can imagine he'll follow
kid's example as best as he can when he
doesn't have a choice then we have momo
and yamato yamato wants momo to fight
kaido and it would be interesting to see
momo's new power in combat if only until
luffy interrupts the fight momo is as
usual scared and not wanting to fight
against kaido because he feels like
he'll just lose especially if even luffy
lost yamato tells him he can fight until
his last breath isn't that the way of
the samurai and again we have the way of
the samurai honorable death discussion
coming about and whereas it is a very
cool code no doubt the arc has made us
question the value of an honorable death
there may be times when it's the only
way but by this point oda has definitely
encouraged us to look for alternative
routes to victory after all odin's death
was epic and very honorable but it would
still be more valuable if he found a way
to survive and actually beat kaido if
everyone strong keeps dying honorable
deaths there will soon be nobody to stop
kaido and protect wano i do respect
yamato though as the daughter of odin
she's ready to fight to the end with
momo she says if not us who everyone is
at their limit and even kaido must be
feeling it now which yeah i wonder how
much he is feeling it because he is good
at not letting anybody notice that he is
feeling anything momo thinks with luffy
gone the only option is to yield and not
throw away more lives yamato who
remember is associated with a guardian
deity of wano through her fruit wants to
defend wano by fighting she refuses to
accept the people of wano being slaves
until the day they die not thinking that
that's any better than death she says
suffering won't save anyone and momo is
panicked not sure what to do she says
all the daimyo that allowed rochi to
have his way went to their graves full
of regret everything wano endured for
the past 20 years was for the sake of
this battle and there's something to be
said also about not being able to just
postpone and postpone battles again and
again she concludes even if surrender is
our only option i'd rather die together
they have this epic moment where they
look at each other and it's implied that
they will go and interfere with kaido
until luffy shows up we know against
kaido yamato didn't do half bad by
herself before and with a new and
upgraded dragon momo i think they'll
definitely be able to buy some time plus
it will be important for the samurai to
see their leader fighting for them so we
can expect to see a fight between them
however brief and i just want to say
yamato's serious determined stare is
absolutely beautiful oda did an amazing
job with this panel kito keeps attacking
causing trouble as luffy is shown
looking pretty lifeless he kind of looks
like he could play the scarecrow from
batman right about now we jump to
zunisha who lets momo know that it can
hear it it really takes it back it can
hear the drums of liberation this is the
first time in 800 years he is there
without a doubt
momo asks who is and zunisha says joy
boy has returned and we see luffy's
melting and smiling face giving off
steam also the grin is written as nikka
making us associate luffy with joyboy
and sun god nika at the same time that's
the end and what an insane chapter it
was so many things we mentioned here
theory-wise turned out to be correct
including that luffy will awaken and
that he is in fact the joy boy and sun
god of the new era oda did not
disappoint we know this is insane for a
lot of reasons one luffy is no longer
quote-unquote luffy since people can't
sense him anymore meaning he's evolved
into something different something
obviously much stronger he'll become
something not seen for 800 years meaning
this is something even more special than
pirate king gold d roger himself oh my
god this is so hype we'll get to see
luffy's awaken form soon the new powers
of it and how this sun god fruit
functions we'll figure out in what way
is luffy not luffy anymore i really hope
it's not an otsutsuki taking over boruto
kind of thing i hope luffy will keep his
will and personality but just have this
upgraded power and perhaps a kind of god
key thing going on like in dragon ball
super where goku is still goku but he
just takes on a new kind of key but let
me know your thoughts what's gonna
happen next who was your mvp in this
chapter and what fruit did luffy consume
what's your favorite of the theories
going around the resin mythical zone or
something else let me know in the
comments and that is it for this one i
said it during the last chapter review i
can't remember the last time i was so
hyped for the next chapter and this time
i'm even more hyped for the next chapter
we'll have to survive a break next week
but i think this chapter had enough hype
to hold us over until then if you did
enjoy this review and want to keep them
coming you know what to do channel the
pirate king within and smash that like
button with you guessed it no mercy just
like kaido smash the cp zero agent you
know no mercy smash it remember smashing
his pirating energy and passing is
scared of energy so choose wisely if you
haven't make this the video subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications or you will miss
future one-piece videos and updates and
while you wait for the next chapter to
drop feel free to check out my huge and
growing one-piece playlist that includes
videos on all the admirals yonko
supernova and much more linked to that
is in the description and until next
time see ya space cowboys bang bang